you performed recently at peach ville
makin babies - he'll make a babies
everything's working you performed it
Patriots owner Robert Kraft birthday
that was a gig that you did that right
how'd it go
that was crazy that was crazy they
wanted me to talk about deflategate
but I wasn't want to disrespect mr.
Kraft like that you know talk about
deflated balls at a 75 year old man Tom
Brady they're armed Brady was there and
I'm they get it they said he's like vote
for Trump and I said you better hope
your left tackle ain't Mexican
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
were there a lot of like a lot of
corporate it was when we got it they see
the private jet for me so we got off the
jet we were right in the party was in a
hangar and it was nothing a billionaires
in there and I had the pleasure of
beating the CEO of Pepsi which is like
the biggest corporation one of the
biggest corporations in the world it
she's really nice and I said it would be
an honor for me to get hit by one of
your truck we begged him in the family
business now my son just got hit by a
guy delivering Chinese food the other
day
you